a farmer used fence post to build a
fence for hazel horse and Polly Pony the
farmer used 26 fence posts to build
hazel horses fence and 19 fence posts to
build Polly ponies fence
how many fence posts did the farmer use
in all and if you like or I encourage
you to pause the video and try to figure
it out so I'm assuming you have tried it
so let's think it through together so
when everything about a word problem
like this a little bit what are they
asking and just what's the story in our
head so farmer is building fence posts
for two different horses hazel horse and
Polly pony and there's even a picture of
Hazel horse here and Polly pony they
look very similar the farmer used 26
fence posts to build Hazel horses fence
so that's these 26 fence post is right
26 fence posts right over here so these
are the 26 fence posts for Hazel horses
fence I haven't counted it but I'll just
take their word for it that they're 26
here and then 19 fence posts to build
Polly ponies fence so these are 19 fence
posts right over here
how many fence posts that the farmer
used in all in all so what do they want
us to do they want us to add or subtract
these numbers well they're looking in
all how many total fence posts did the
farmer use well the total is how many
used in Hazel's fence and Polly's fence
so we should add these two numbers so
we're going to add 26 plus the 19 or let
me see the 26 is in that brownish color
26
that's the 26 fence post to build Hazel
horses fence and we're going to add that
to 19 we're going to add that to 19 so
26 for hazel horse and then 19 for Polly
pony we want to add them because we're
saying how many fence posts were used in
all if we combine in Hazel's and Polly's
fences so let's add these two together
so first let's go to the ones place six
ones plus nine ones
is 15 ones but we don't we only write
one digit here so 15 ones is the same
thing as five ones and one 10 right 15
is just one ten and five ones so we've
essentially regrouped that those 10 ones
as one 10 right over here or some people
say you carry the 1 but that's all
that's saying we're seeing 6 plus 9 is
15 15 is 5 ones and 1 10 we wrote that
one 10 in the tens place and then 1 10
plus 2 tens plus 1 10 well 1 plus 2 plus
1 is 4 so it's going to be 4 tens so 45
how many fence posts using all 44 85 now
some of y'all that might have somehow
tried to maybe subtract the 19 4 20 from
26 that would have been what you would
have done if they said how many more
fence posts did the the farmer used for
Hazel's fence than for Polly's then you
would subtract 19 from 26 to find the
difference but they didn't ask us how
many more fence posts were used for
Hazelden for Polly or how many fewer
fence posts were used for Polly than
hazel they didn't ask us that they said
how many fence posts did the farmer use
in all and that's why we added